Guten Morgen Linus.
Morgen, Liebe. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich äh bin irgendwie immer noch so auf Pluto eingestellt und komme da irgendwie noch nicht so ganz,
zurecht, aber ich merke natürlich schon äh wie die Gravitationswellen hier einiges in Wallung gebracht haben.
Netzpolitik hundertneunundsechzig äh live aus dem Raumfahrtkulturzentrum im Preslauer Berg,
Ja, habe schon immer geahnt. Jetzt äh jetzt haben wir, jetzt haben wir so ein äh können wir mal gucken, wie wir das Ding nennen, ne? Kann ja jeder auch einen Vorschlag machen.
Ne, er ist ja eher äh IX.
Ja, Pech gehabt.
Tut's allen wieder leid.
Nee, was der andere Name, oder sowas, ne, bei den.
Ich habe noch nicht genau geguckt, also.
Den Lunis gibt's dann immer so verschiedene.
Also nach wem könnte man jetzt gerade meinen Planeten benennen? Jetzt ärgert man sich natürlich, dass wir Lemmy Kirmes da schon für dieses äh für dieses chemische Element äh verballern wollen.
Das Element vorgeschlagen. Ja, mal gucken, ne? Ne, ich meine, David Boey würde sich noch anbieten.
Bowie. Ja, das wäre schon, also der hat Bowie ein.
Könnte schon mal Planet ja einfach Planet Bowie. Warum nicht?
Naja, wir haben das wahrscheinlich am Ende wieder nicht äh zu entscheiden, wie immer. Nee, wir haben so gute.
Uns fragt wieder keiner. Keiner fragt die Basis.
Die Basis ist raus. Nee, das äh die wahren Entscheidungen werden immer in kleinen Kreisen gefällt. Weißt du, wie das ist, ne? Ist schlimm.
Genau. Aber immerhin äh wir arbeiten dran unsere Basis äh zu verbreitern und die Zirkel etwas aufzubrechen und äh haben heute noch einen Gast an Bord.
Den Alexander Alexander Sander, hallo,
Willkommen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Ähm.
Alex, du bist ähm ja, du bist äh aktiv und zwar bei der digitalen Gesellschaft.
Vielleicht kannst du ja mal selber,
erzählen, was da so euer äh Zentral eure zentralen Inhalte und Aktivitäten sind.
Eure primäre, wie soll ich sagen, also,
was siehst du so als euren Hauptwirkungsvektor?
Würdest du die.
Ja, dazu gehört natürlich auch so ein gewisser Früherkennungsaspekt, also man muss dann eben auch die Nase schon äh längst im Wind haben, wenn die Düfte anfangen herüberzuziehen,
häufig
Wird man ja oder wurde sagen wir der Aktivismus auch immer ganz gerne überrollt von mehr oder weniger fertigen Ergebnissen mit Klassiker ist immer so, oh der Bundestag will morgen über irgendwas abstimmen, äh das gefällt uns aber gar nicht, da sind wir ja jetzt mal kurz dagegen,
äh bringt natürlich herzlich wenig. Was würdest du sagen, ist so der Zeitpunkt, wo man eigentlich spätestens.
Bekommen haben sollte.
Und würdest du sagen, dass derzeit der Trend deutlich hin mehr zu europäischer Aktivität geht oder ist das äh hält sich das noch die Waage oder hat man dann letzten Endes doch National den größeren Hebel, weil man da besser verankert ist.
Also die gegessen ist auch unterstützendes Mitglied beim Etri. Hm und mit wie viel Leuten seid ihr so am Start?
Mhm. Ihr macht ja auch äh hier so eine Veranstaltungsreihe in Berlin, gehe ich mal gerne hin. Äh erster Dienstag im Monat, ne, äh in der Seabase. Finde ich eigentlich immer ganz ähm.
Soll ich sagen? Also sehr beständig. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange läuft das jetzt schon?
So lange wie wir jetzt hier unseren Podcast machen und
Regelmäßigkeit ist äh auf jeden Fall immer mit fast die Größe äh Herausforderung bei sowas. Ich weiß, dass
wohl, aber sind wir sehr unterschiedliche Themen, zwei, drei, manchmal auch ein paar mehr Vorträge, mal mehr Diskussionen, mal mehr einfach nur so Updates über über was auch immer, so ähnlich wie wir das dann eben auch hier machen, aber auf jeden Fall auch immer so ein
Sammelpunkt dieser sag mal nutzpolitisch bewegten Szene und,
Grad an dem Event habe ich auch mal ganz gut gesehen, also korrigiere mich, wenn du einen anderen Eindruck hast, aber soweit ich mich erinnere, das war so vor vier, fünf Jahren,
Da saßen da so zwanzig, dreißig Leute rum und mittlerweile ist eigentlich die Seabase immer voll.
Ja ich auch, vor allem weil's dann auch verhältnismäßig kompakt ist. Es läuft zwei Stunden, ne?
Und uns hat halt auch, ich meine auch zu, manchmal komme ich hin und
ist eh so voll und und nutz einfach mal die Gelegenheit einfach nur, weil du einfach, ich weiß, da stehen dann irgendwie zehn, zwanzig Leute rum, wenn ich mir die alle zusammen telefonieren sollte, eh, über die Woche, eh, hätte ich da sehr viel mehr mit zu tun. Und da kann man dann halt mal eben schnell
Sachen klären, ne, so äh Einladung aussprechen, Hintergründe abfragen et cetera und von daher,
erfüllt das natürlich hier auch eine gewisse soziale,
Rolle.
Ja, über PNR wollen wir dann auch gleich noch reden, aber ich glaube, äh zunächst einmal müssen wir uns noch hier in eine kleine Feedback äh Schleife begeben und einen kleinen Nachtrag liefern zu einem Thema des letzten Lokboos.
Genau, da ging's um Binge und äh wir hatten ja erst auch selber im Laufe der Sendung den Verdacht erhärtet, wie das denn funktioniert und sind dann relativ,
erst zum Ende hin, dass auf die,
plumpste Idee gekommen, nämlich dass man einfach den Traffic bei diesen Videostreams
drosselt und dadurch dabei auf das auf die adaptive Bandbreitenanpassung setzt, also im Prinzip der Nutzer geht hin und klickt einen.
HD Stream, dann äh ist dazwischen T-Mobile und begrenzt, aber die Bandbreite auf anderthalb MB, der
Server, der die Datei streamt und bereitstellt, merkt,
er nicht schnell genug senden kann und schaltet automatisch runter. Sieht man auch
Tagesschau aus der Mediathek schaut und dann mit so einem äh Unterschichten Provider wie ich unterwegs ist, so dann
merkt man halt so, dass ruckelt ganz schön und da wird halt alles gedrosselt was was,
So, genau.
Und jetzt hat die das Problem wäre natürlich, was,
Anpassung hat,
Ja, also was, sagen wir mal, ein äh naiver Streamingserver, der gar nicht das kann, ja, der vielleicht gar nicht in nicht HD bereitstellen kann,
Und genau das hat die IFF jetzt auch nochmal untersucht und hat gesagt, naja okay, wir haben mal geguckt.
Ähm wenn man ein paar Test Cases gemacht und uns so eine Karte geholt von T-Mobile und,
und sagen OK also erstens,
diese Limitierung auf anderthalb äh Megabit passiert bei Videodateien.
Ob die Anbieter wollen oder nicht. Also es ist eine Drosselung, die einfach mal für alle gilt. Ähm,
funktioniert auch, wenn die HTTP-Headers einen anderen Dateitypen definieren, was so ein bisschen unklar ist, das heißt, woher merken die jetzt genau, dass es sich um Videoinhalte handelt so?
Das kann die IFF auch selber nicht genau sagen, also das wäre.
Kann mir nur vorstellen, dass sie damit einer arbeiten. Also äh die werden da einfach eine Liste pflegen, wo draufsteht das sind für uns die Videodienste, die wir kennen. Wenn du jetzt von irgendeinem Server da einen Video bereitstellst, dann ist das bestimmt nicht.
Spezifisch gedrosselt so.
Das wäre jetzt auch meine Hypothese, allerdings haben sie dann einen Server, haben sie.
Entschuldigung. Blacklist meine ich natürlich, ne?
Ja. Aber dann haben sie, haben sie einen Server aufgestellt, der keine keine adaptive äh Bandbreitenanpassung macht und der ruckelte dann einfach.
Das heißt, da hat wurde auch auf anderthalb Mbit gedrosselt.
Dieser Hypothese sind sie auch äh nachgegangen,
und haben äh einen normalen Datei-Download gemacht und haben damit äh sehr viel höhere Bandbreiten erzielt. Also quasi drei Test Cases, du streamst ein Video, du lädst eine eine Datei herunter und du.
Du du lädst dir ein Video herunter, gibst aber im im HTTP Header nicht an, dass es sich um ein Video handelt. Und in in den,
und in den anderen äh also Streaming im Browser Direct download und direct download,
Non-Video wurden gedrosselt. Also irgendwie erkennen sie's doch ganz gut. Ja, also.
Anschauen und darauf irgendwelche, ja, wie sollen sie es sonst wissen? Ich meine, wenn da alles über harte TPS rübergeht, wie wie.
Der, der, na ja, also genau, erstens,
Ja, es war nicht nur HTPS, wir hatten ja auch elaboriert, dass wenn es HTPS ist, dann müssen sie mehr oder weniger einfach auf Basis des Anbieters gehen oder halt auf Größe der Datei oder ne, also, aber.
Die kennen sie auch nicht.
Na ja, sie sehen ja, dass da auf einmal ein Stream stattfindet. Also nichts ist so einfach zu erkennen, wie ein Videostream oder ein Skype-Telefonat. An der.
Ach so, du meinst, dass sie das sozusagen so so Trafficanalyse machen und so, also das ist okay.
Punkt, auf den ich hinaus will, ist, die haben es untersucht und können keine hundertprozentige,
Aussage treffen und ich ey, ich schildere deren Ergebnisse. Wir können da jetzt noch ein bisschen drüber spekulieren, aber die haben das schon ganz gut untersucht. So, ja. Und sie sagen also, sie wissen nicht ganz genau, wie es geht. Und dieser der interessante Fall ist eben
bei diesen, wenn der harte TP hätte er nicht stimmt und sage ich mal, keine.
Dafür da sind, dass es sich um einen Videostream handelt, funktioniert dieses diese Binge on Drossel doch,
Trotzdem, ja? Also, ob sie jetzt irgendwie nach Markern wie Video ähm.
Äh was weiß ich wie in dem Video Code in dem übertragenen Teil nach irgendwelchen Markern suchen oder nicht, ist irgendwie unklar,
Also ist nicht ganz so einfach, dass sie einfach nur sagen, okay, YouTube grundsätzlich nur anderthalb Mbit. Das haben sie wahrscheinlich auch, aber ihr, was auch immer sie da jetzt einsetzen kann, auch,
sage ich mal, bei der Tele,
nicht bekannten Videostreaming angeboten,
erkennen, dass es sich um ein Video-Streaming-Angebot handelt und das sogar auch, wenn,
das ein bisschen verfälscht und jetzt nicht, sage ich mal, die offensichtlichen Marker dran sind, wie HTP Header oder Filextension, die jetzt einfach erkennbar wären.
Also mit anderen Worten, das würde auch bei äh wie gesagt, bei MediaZ, sagen wir mal.
Wäre mal interessant.
Media CTC würde das eben auch einfach,
bei WDR CCA, wobei ich nicht weiß, ob Media CCC DE,
automatische Bandbreitenanpassung macht,
Da bin ich gerade nicht im Bilde, weil ich in der Regel einfach HD beste Qualität.
Ist vielleicht gar nicht so das Ding oder ist halt eher die Frage Streaming, in dem Moment, wo du halt HLS äh Streaming machst, also also adaptive ich halte mehrere Bandbreiten äh vor und bilde das aus, was am besten oder beziehungsweise der der Klein wählt ja aus, was äh,
Was sozusagen äh letztlich abgefragt wird, weil er merkt, dass äh die anderen Häppchen nicht schnell genug kommen. Schaltet der Kleint ja dann selber runter,
Muss man sehen. Äh sicherlich noch ein paar Tests wert. So oder so ist es vollkommen offensichtlich, dass hier T-Mobile USA halt
einfach mal genau das macht, was äh Kritiker einer
Netzneutralitätsregelung, also eine antinetz Neutralitätsregelung immer kritisiert haben. Und das, obwohl es jetzt eben
die eigentlich äh korrekte ähm Definition für Netzneutralität äh ja eigentlich geschafft hat in den USA
Jetzt wird's natürlich spannend zu sein, zu sehen, ob die FCC hier auch
Regeln nicht nur auf dem Papier stehen, sondern sich eben auch real im Netz messen lassen.
Jo, was noch ganz schön ist, dass sie dann eben Mitte in,
telefoniert haben mit weil ja,
der John Leger ja groß erzählt, dass optimiert, optimiert, optimiert und so, ne? Und dann haben sie halt
weil Timo, weil angerufen haben gesagt, ja äh wie sieht's denn hier aus so was seit's irgendwie so von Optimierung wen ich jetzt unbedingt zu erkennen und da haben eben auch am Telefon die Antwort bekommen, dass da jetzt nix großartig,
optimiert wird, ja. Also,
Sie haben da offensichtlich mal jemanden ans Telefon bekommen, der.
Der weiß was Sache ist und sagte so also irgendeine Umkudierung oder Optimierung oder sonst was äh findet da nicht statt, was ja meine,
ursprüngliche Prothese war in meinem äh naiven, in meiner naiven Leichtgläubigkeit, wenn jemand sagt, wir optimieren etwas, dass ich dachte, ah okay, äh der nimmt das und optimiert das, aber äh machen's einfach nur kaputt. Also.
Jetzt ist es die eigentliche Bedeutung von Optimier.
Sie optimieren das für sich.
Optimieren das in Grund und Boden.
Und dann hatten wir ja in der letzten Sendung ähm gesagt, man man möge doch bitte den äh Soprano's Clusterfuck mal visualisieren.
Das haben äh zwei höhere gemacht, nämlich einmal,
Nelako, das Bild von ihm haben wir auch schon direkt ähm.
In der in den zur Sendung hundertachtundsechzig eingebunden,
und wir haben noch eine zweite Einreichung bekommen, die wir bis jetzt noch nicht veröffentlicht hatten, die kam von Ben, äh und Ben hat das noch so angereichert mit den.
Mit äh Aquarellen von.
Stella, den Nachnamen sage ich jetzt nicht, weil der sehr schwer ist. Ich glaube, er ist fängt mit S an,
Auf, Schiff,
Auf jeden Fall die Stella, die auch äh immer mal wieder bei dem äh Podcast technische Aufklärung zu Gast ist,
die sich immer in den NSA Untersuchungsausschuss setzt und dort Zeichnungen von den,
Insassen äh anfertigt und somit Aquarellfarben auch koloriert, weil man da ja nicht fotografieren darf.
Ähm.
Ich gehe da mal ganz steil voran und sage Stella Shiftschick.
Weil sie das auf ihrer Seite nochmal in Lautschrift stehen hat.
Nö, das steht jetzt hier so im Text, aber das äh ich bin halt mutig, ne? Ja. Bin äh ich gehe voran einfach.
Ja, okay. Mal gucken, ob ob der Ben nach dieser Sendung die Bilder immer noch benutzen.
Da kenne ich einfach kein halten.
Gut, also da haben wir eine Visualisierung und da sieht man äh sehr schön, wie,
so verschiedene Personen wie also halt Klaus-Dieter äh,
Vizepräsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz war, dann Geheimdienstkoordinator, dann Staatssekretär im Innenministerium, dann,
ähm,
zwei Jahre lang gar, also keine keine der aufgezählten Posten und dann eben äh Beauftragter für die Nachrichtendienste im Bundeskanzleramt,
Also das ist echt ganz geil, was dieser bunte Reigen, der da entsteht.
Dass sie so in allen in allen Positionen mal äh rotieren.
Genau, ich denke, da ist visualisierungstechnisch auch noch ein bisschen was zu holen.
Ja genau, also es.
Indem man mehr so den die Verlaufs und Zusammenhangslinien äh äh noch deutlicher macht und vielleicht.
Genau, ich hatte auch vorgeschlagen, man könnte das jetzt so mit mit HTML fünf oder so, dass man.
Quasi wechseln kann jetzt haben wir halt die Linien.
Es ist gerne interaktiv.
Ja unter also Multimedia auf jeden Fall.
Genau, surfen,
filmen durch die Welt mit Multi Media.
Genau, wir haben auf jeden Fall verschiedene äh oder wir haben zwei Visualisierungen, wenn die auch,
herzlich für diese Beiträge, die wir da erhalten haben und das ist tatsächlich sehr schön in beiden dargestellt.
So, das bringt uns zu unserem Hauptthema heute.
Genau.
Das Hauptthema ist äh.
Birgt sich hinter dem kurzen, kryptischen ähm äh Kürzel P N R, das steht für Passenger Name Records, heißt aber eigentlich,
besser, also gemeint sind natürlich die Daten, die anfallen,
Ähm die gespeichert werden müssen über die Passagiere,
von äh Flugzeugen des zivilen Luftverkehrs, des Linienverkehrs, wo halt äh drinsteht, wer fliegt hier? Wo kommt der her? Äh wo wir da hin,
Was für ein äh na, Nationalität ist am Start und natürlich ganz wichtig, äh was für ein Essen wurde bestellt.
Ähm Alexander, vielleicht kannst du mal so ein bisschen deine Perspektive da,
dem Thema ausrollen, was ist da eigentlich bisher,
gelaufen. Das Thema ist ja nicht neu, sondern das wollte uns jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen länger,
und ähm erzähl doch mal, warum ihr da so aktiv seid und was.
Was ist das sonst noch so?
Also kein MacBook, sondern mhm.
Fünfzehn.
Welcher Ausschuss äh beschäftigt sich damit?
Die normale VDS.
Okay, gegen Penner schon, okay. Mhm.
Rahmen welches Prozesses haben die dagegen äh gestimmt, also was stand,
an der gab's dann auch schon einen Vorschlag von von der Kommission.
Genau und das Parlament.
Dagegen gestimmt.
Aber im Wesentlichen sozusagen die Negierung der, der, der, der Kernziele. Und jetzt kommt es sozusagen nochmal.
Das ist ja eine sehr, sehr ungewöhnliche Konstellation. Das A, das Plenum jetzt einerseits dem dem Ausschuss nicht folgt. Das ist ja schon.
Eher selten und dass dann sozusagen das jetzt sozusagen so lange nochmal weiter beraten wird, bis bis wirklich der der Ausschuss eine komplette andere Richtung hat. Müssen wir mal kurz darüber nachdenken. Zweitausendelf sagst du,
Wann waren denn jetzt nochmal die EU-Wahlen? Also haben wir da zwischendurch.
Wir hatten da sozusagen eine Parlamentsänderung. Das heißt, das hat's in der Legislaturperiode dann nicht mehr geschafft und dann mit der neuen Bestückung
einer neuen Zusammensetzung. Und was hat sich äh hast du irgendwie einen Eindruck? Äh was genau an dieser Zusammensetzung dieses Ausschusses dazu geführt haben
also gab's da jetzt irgendwie eine Verschiebung in der Parteienlandschaft oder andere.
Ist es noch der selbe Berichterstatter.
Aber der war auch schon bei der ersten.
Jetzt läuft die Wirtschaft wieder ein bisschen und mehr Terror.
Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du das das Parlament dann wiederum äh dem Vorschlag,
Innenausschusses nicht folgen möchte und vielleicht diesmal in die andere Richtung marschiert.
Gibt's denn überhaupt Fraktionen, die da sich klar positioniert haben gegen so eine Verschärfung?
Na die sind ja immer sehr prinzipientreu unterwegs.
Fragt sich nur gerade, was.
Des Tages ist.
Wie organisiert ihr jetzt sozusagen die nächsten zwei Wochen? Was sind eure Aktivitätsziele?
Hm. Ähm.
Vielleicht können wir nochmal ein bisschen auf die Daten eingehen. Soll da auch gespeichert werden, wann ich wohin geflogen bin?
Und der wird aufbewahrt für wie lange? Fünf Jahre.
Gibt's denn in irgendeiner Form im Rahmen dieser ähm,
Diskussion im Innenausschuss,
oder auch bei der Kommission, also in irgendeiner Form an der Stelle, wo über Änderungen diskutiert wird, auch,
konkrete Bedenken im Hinblick auf diese Anonymisierung, also,
gibt's gibt's irgendwelche abfedernden Aspekte, die da überhaupt noch mit drin sind? Oder ist der derzeitige,
Beschluss eher so mit, wir speichern alles, wir werten alles aus, wir speichern es ewig und äh seid mal ruhig, weil wir müssen ja hier was gegen Terror tun oder sind da irgendwelche Abwägungen drin?
Tastaturbenutzung.
Erfasst.
Aber nicht nicht als standardisierter Rekord, das steht da nicht drin jetzt.
Fleisch essen. Mhm.
Ja, ich denke, die rufen dann Herrn Graulich an und der setzt sich da in den Keller und äh blättert da äh das alles durch.
Ja. Umfeld nochmal etwas klarer zu machen, wohin die Daten zu welchem Zeitpunkt gehen. Also ich kaufe mir ein Ticket,
Da fallen ja schon mal Daten an, weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen schon Teil dieser Speicherung ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt, kann sein, wahrscheinlich ja.
Spätestens, wenn ich einchecke, ist ja sozusagen der Fakt,
will da jetzt mitfliegen auch erfasst. Ähm.
Dann sitze ich im Flugzeug. Ist das der Zeitpunkt? Also,
ist ja dieser soll ja dieser Datensatz in gewisser Hinsicht schon verfügbar sein. Das war ja insbesondere der Wunsch der Amerikaner, dass da sozusagen am besten gar nicht erst jemand auch nur ins Flugzeug gelassen wird, der, der äh was machen könnte, richtig?
Also wenn jemand umgebucht wird und so was, das passiert.
Okay, das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die Tür zugeht, so und was ist das für eine Organisation, diese was hast du gerade gesagt?
Okay und wer betreibt die dann? Oder soll betreiben? Die gibt's derzeit noch nicht so, ne?
Könnte beim Innenministerium landen, könnte beim Geheimdienst landen, könnte bei der.
Keine Vorgabe so.
Ist eigentlich schon mal interessant, ne, dass an der Stelle auch noch nicht mal so in Richtlinie ist das eine Richtlinie eigentlich? Ja, ne?
Gibt's diese Informationsstellen, die sammeln die sozusagen erstmal so als Proxi ein oder sind das,
Also sind ihnen dann nur zu einem,
Es geht's da drum, die zentral zu speichern, gibt's dann auf EU-Ebene nochmal eine zentrale Sammelstelle oder verbleibt das erstmal äh in.
Aber von separaten Identitäten immer auf Basis von expliziten Anfragen ist es jetzt noch nicht soweit.
Da ein Verbundenes hat, wo jeder jede Datenbank jederzeit anfragen.
Okay, aber Europol kriegt auch immer eine Kopie.
So ein gewisser Level an Auffälligkeit sozusagen erreicht ist. Mhm.
Wer eure Kritik ist ja im Prinzip des Missbrauchspotential, weil es sich ja hier letztlich auch nur um eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung äh handelt, wenn jetzt auch mit einer anderen Ausrichtung und Ansiedlung
Ich denke, was auch noch so ein bisschen im Raum steht, ist so diese generelle Angst, dass in dem Moment, wo das für Flugdaten mal eingeführt ist, dass wir da nicht mehr lange brauchen, bis wir das dann auch für
keine Ahnung, Mautstrecken et cetera auch haben.
Also sie sind hier so noch nicht Teil dieser Abstimmung, da geht's jetzt wirklich nur ums Flugverkehr, aber man weiß die Daten sind ja da, ne? Mhm. Carsharing.
Weil das kann ja nicht sein, dass und so weiter. Ja.
Läuft's. Linus.
Ein Aspekt den du gerne noch äh beleuchten möchtest oder.
Bin seit Jahren.
Deine Daten oder was?
Was heißt denn das? Die personalisiert, bei wem werden sie DPD.
Also wir nur angezeigt, wenn man's möchte. Genau.
Werden immer.
Ja, du weißt doch, wenn auch nur ein Opfer geschützt werden kann, dann.
Dann dann das alles, dann war's das alles wert, ja.
Ja, ich meine, wir machen ja immer gerne äh die äh die Witze mit dem Heu und,
stehen äh Stecknadeln. War ganz stolz, dass Sascha Loh auch äh,
mein äh ruft nach mehr Heu jetzt äh in seine Kolumne getragen hat. Ähm.
Andererseits wissen wir natürlich auch, dass die ähm,
Deep-Learning und so weiter, lassen ja durchaus auch
Absehen, dass sagen wir mal die potenzielle Informations,
aus solchen Datenmengen
dass sich das auch mal ändern kann, ja? Ich meine, man macht ja immer ganz gerne mal so
sein was wollt ihr denn mit den ganzen Daten? Ihr seid doch eh zu doof da irgendwelche nennenswerten Schlussfolgerungen draus zu ziehen, das ist ja äh in unseren Kreisen auch sehr beliebt, aber ich glaube die sehr viel größere Gefahr liegt dadrin, dass sich das nämlich dann auch mal ändert. Das eben sehr wohl,
Ich mag auch gar nicht ausschließen, dass sowas vielleicht auch mal wirklich zu einer Aufspürung,
Verdächtiger oder vielleicht eben auch konkret gefährlicher Menschen führen kann.
Weil,
auch da glaube ich, dass die, ich will das jetzt gar nicht schön reden, aber nur mal so auch dieser politischen Argumentation, der anderen Seite ein bisschen folgen zu können,
die das anders sehen, dass die sozusagen dieses, nur weil die Daten da jetzt mal mit untersucht werden und mit in diesen Algorithmus einfließen,
geht da ja noch nicht automatisch einen Verdacht
hervor, im Sinne eines ähm rechtsrelevanten Prozesses, es ist ja nicht so, dass sie,
an deine Tür klopft, nur weil die Daten da jetzt mitprozessiert werden. Das ist äh äh sicherlich nachvollziehbar.
Ähm trotzdem die Frage ist natürlich auch,
und wie viel Zutrauen kann man so einem Algorithmus letzten Endes äh auch äh gewähren, weil in dem Moment, wo dann eben die Lampe aufleuchtet und sagt,
ist gefährlich, weil unser Computer hat das gesagt
sehen wir ja auch schon, wie diese Gläubigkeit in, in, in solche Systeme, weil hat ja schon mal funktioniert oder zumindest haben die Programmierer immer gesagt,
das funktionieren würde und wenn's mal die Lampe leuchtet, dann ist das schon relevant. Das
Das ist dann auch sehr schwer ist.
Sich diesem auch noch in irgendeiner Form zu entziehen. Also dann ist ja sozusagen auch ein Verdacht ausgesprochen, der dann auch wirklich äh konkret wird und und und konkrete Auswirkungen haben kann, dem man fast gar nichts entgegen äh setzen kann.
Fly, also nur auf der No-Fly-Liste zu landen, alleine, das schließt einem ja im Prinzip von äh Reisen, Geschäftsbeziehungen, et cetera,
auch nur politische Aktivität eigentlich äh aus, also auch in Europa wäre jetzt was weiß ich, wenn du jetzt nicht mehr fliegen könntest.
Immer noch äh E-Mail und
äh den Zug aber so richtig spannend wäre es nicht. Und wenn es sich dann halt auch noch auf Mietwagen,
Carsharing, Züge und Schiffe auch noch ausdehnt in dem Moment, ist man ja im Prinzip schon.
So, was kann man tun äh wenn man.
Sache jetzt noch unterstützen möchte, insbesondere in den nächsten zwei Wochen, dann geht man zum No P NR Punkt ORG.
Vielen Dank Alexander erstmal für,
die Ausführung hier zu PNR wollten wir schon immer mal ein bisschen ausführlicher behandeln,
jetzt auch mal gemacht,
Was haben wir denn äh sonst noch auf der Agenda?
Mobilfunküberwachung haben wir.
Mal was ganz anderes.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ein so ein Klassiker, der
Standardsituationen der kleinen Anfragen der Linksfraktion, die erkundigen sich in regelmäßigen Abständen nach den Überwachungsmaßnahmen im Mithilfebereich. Ähm das geht, glaube ich, immer so von Andre
Und da haben sie sich nach äh mehreren Maßnahmen erkundigt. Erstens,
die nach der Verwendung der stillen SMS.
Stille SMS. Ähm ich hatte das hier schon öfter mal erklärt, aber der Vollständigkeit halber erkläre ich's nochmal. Das ist eine äh quasi ein.
Standard, den es in der Definition von SMS gibt,
Da gibt es verschiedene SMS-Nachrichten, Typen, über die das,
deren Empfang das Telefon den Nutzer nicht in Kenntnis setzt,
ist es vorgesehen. Ähm die haben,
Unterschiedliche, es gibt unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten, stille SMS zu schicken. Das eine ist irgendwie einfach Typ null und dann die wird einfach den Empfang wird einfach,
Bestätigt und dann ist gut. Ähm man kann aber auch binäre SMS an die SIM-Karte schicken und damit,
keine sinnvolle Aktion auslösen, aber es gibt also,
ein ein Standard konformes Mobiltelefon wird,
Empfang dem Netz gegenüber bestätigen, aber äh den Nutzern nicht anzeigen. Es gibt auch
Darauf habe ich, glaube ich, auch mehrmals hingewiesen. Ähm,
Möglichkeiten, sein Telefon dazu zu bringen, zumindest zu warnen, dass eine solche SMS gekommen ist,
ähm das äh können die Apps,
Ketchup, Ketchup und ähm Snoops,
an deren Entwicklung ich nicht vollständig unbeteiligt war, weil sie aus einem von einem Team entwickelt wurden, mit dem ich ähm,
zu tun habe.
Immer am Bahnhof gesoffen hast.
Man muss das ja als Disclaimer dazu sagen, wenn das aus der eigenen Schmiede kommt. Ähm.
Und diese warum macht man, warum setzten Straffverfolgungsbehörden die ein? Ähm man würde ja eigentlich meinen, ist völlig ähm,
uninteressant, aber letztendlich ist die Gesetzeslage so,
Dass eine Strafverfolgungsbehörde nicht,
so einfach zum ähm zu einem,
Mobilfunknetz gehen durfte und sagen durfte, sag uns doch mal bitte, äh wo der Nutzer gerade ist.
Das geht zwar auch, auch das habe ich, glaube ich, hier schon öfter erzählt, das Telefon das Mobilfunknetz weiß, wo ihr seid, damit es
eure Transaktionen, über die Zellen abwickeln kann, in denen ihr euch tatsächlich auch befindet, also euer Mobiltelefon, sagt dem Mobilfunknetz auch immer, wo ihr seid, aber auf diese Daten gibt es keinen.
Wann ihr eine äh Transaktion durchgeführt habt,
so eingehende oder ausgehende Nachrichten oder Anrufe oder Internet oder so
und dann natürlich auch, über welche Zelle die abgewickelt wurden. Und was der der quasi der juristische Hack war, den Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdienste da zur Anwendung bringen, ist
Naja, wenn wir die Daten nur kriegen, wenn's eine Transaktion gibt, dann machen wir halt eine Transaktion, also schicken wir stille SMS.
In Zeitabständen, die wir für für richtig halten und am Ende des Monats holen wir uns dann eben die Transaktionsdaten,
dann sieht man in den Transaktionsdaten eben, ja, hat, äh, weiß ich nicht, ein paar hundert SMS bekommen und war zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo er diese SMS bekommen hat, jeweils in diesen Zellen und dann kannst du wieder mappen
wo wo diese Zellen waren, dann kannst du damit quasi Location-Tracking machen, etwas, was eigentlich eben den nicht.
Direkt erlaubt ist.
So und jetzt hat das BKA im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn insgesamt einhundertsechzehntausendneunhundertachtundvierzig stille SMS versendet,
Ähm.
Diese Zahl ist natürlich jetzt halt interessant. So, die Frage ist, mit welcher also die Zahl sagt erstmal nichts aus, weil,
Grob überschlagen, hättest du wenn du die einfach sehr schnell sendest, hättest die auch alle an eine Person schicken können, ja? Ähm,
und sie werden sich halt verschiedene zeitliche Auflösungen für unterschiedliche Zielpersonen gesetzt haben. Man weiß auch nicht, ob sie die einfach rund um die Uhr schicken
bei Interesse, mal gucken, oh, wo war der zu dem Zeitpunkt, war der bei der Demo oder nicht? Ne, also.
Also salopp gesagt, es könnte sein, dass sie hunderttausend Mal bei hunderttausend Leuten einmal wissen wollten, wo die sind, aber es kann auch sein, dass sie bei einer Person hunderttausend Mal wissen wollten, wo die ist.
Irgendwo dazwischen wird, die wird sich die Wahrheit ähm.
Verbergen interessant ist aber im zweiten Halbjahr,
zweitausendvierzehn, also im gleichen Zeitraum ein Jahr vorher, haben sie sechsundzwanzigtausend verschickt. Das heißt, sie haben das,
verfünffacht. Ja, in zwei, im und im ersten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn,
Also hatten sie, haben sie zweiundzwanzigtausend verschickt? Also irgendwas ging echt mal hoch im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn, nämlich sie haben auf einmal fünfmal so viele SMS versendet.
Äh der Verfassungsschutz hat äh.
Er äh hatte der Verfassungsschutz hundertzweiundvierzigtausend verschickt,
Und jetzt im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn nur noch fünfundvierzigtausend. Also irgendwie das BKA hat mehr gemacht, der Verfassungsschutz weniger.
Zoll, Bundesnachrichtendienst und der militärische Abschirmdienst nutzen die auch, geben aber ihre Zahlen nicht raus.
Und alle sagen vor allem auch jetzt nicht, wie viele Personen davon betroffen war.
Wie viele Personen sagen sie nicht? Sie sagen nur, die Gesamtzahl dieser äh dieser SMS und die gesagt, diese diese,
Zahl ist wenig aussagekräftig, aber wenn man jetzt mal,
zu Grunde legt, dass die im Zweifelsfall halbwegs,
Rational mit diesem Ding umgehen und die nicht zu oft verschenken und nicht zu wenig würde ich,
eigentlich eher damit rechnen, dass sie sowas wie ein wie fünf, dreißig oder sechzig Minuten als zeitliche Auflösung nehmen. Ja, also du willst ja, dich interessiert ja nicht unbedingt, wo ist die Person langgefahren, ja?
Ich habe aber auch schon mal im Rahmen einer ähm.
Also ich habe mal Einsicht in solche äh Protokolle bekommen. Da war die zeitliche Auflösung auch so im,
etwas also im Mehr, mehrere Minutenbereich.
Wie sind die räumliche Auflösung? Also ist da jetzt eine Triankulation möglich oder kriegt man im Prinzip nur eine Zelle mit?
Kriegst nur die und die übersetzt im Prinzip erstmal nur in einen in ein hundertzwanzig Grad Winkel abgehend von dem Standort der Antenne.
Mehrere Antennen oder mehrere.
Nee, wenn du also wenn du mehrere solche Messungen hast, ne, dann siehst du natürlich, okay, weil also deshalb interessiert dich unter Umständen vielleicht auch schon ein Weg,
Eine Straße, weil die jetzt von der Einzelmessung nicht weiß, welche welche Straße ist sie jetzt wohl gefahren, aber wenn du halt einfach sage ich mal zwanzig Zellen hast, die entlang der Autobahn stehen, dann kannst du die halt relativ einfach ausmalen. Okay, Person wird jetzt da.
Auf der Butter gefahren sein. Was natürlich auch äh ein Grund sein kann, warum mehr,
SMS gesendet werden, weil sie einfach gesehen haben, wir umso häufiger wir abfragen, umso genauere Tracks können wir daraus äh nachvollziehen. Also von daher, interessante Zahl, schwer zu interpretieren.
Interessanter, also interessanter wird die vor allem, wenn dich, wenn dich Zusammenkünfte von Personen interessieren,
dann kann's natürlich einfach sagen, okay, die sind echt einfach, weißt du?
Aus verschiedenen Richtungen gekommen. Stundenlang zusammengehangen.
Die sind aus verschiedenen Richtungen gekommen und dann war der eine zwei Stunden in dieser E Plus Zelle und der andere zwei Stunden in der Tim-Mobile-Zelle, die daneben steht und dann sind die zum gleichen Zeitpunkt dann wieder aus dem Bereich raus, der eine in die eine und der andere in die andere Richtung, ja?
Ähm.
Stille SMS heißt ich.
Ich habe diese Person, ich will die Person im Auge behalten und ich mache ich verwandle im Prinzip ihr Mobiltelefon, was sie in der Tasche hat, in eine Ortungswanze. Ja, also,
Das ist das, obwohl ich das eigentlich, obwohl die Rechtsprechung mir das im Prinzip nicht erlaubt,
habe ich halt quasi diesen juristischen Hack und äh hole mir am Ende des Monats oder vielleicht sogar früher die Transaktionsrecords, ja? Und missbrauche ähm quasi die,
Telekommunikationsüberwachung zur Location-Überwachung. Spielt ja dann auch nochmal wieder eine Rolle
im Rahmen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wo er jetzt auch,
anfallen. Das heißt, da wird's auch nochmal interessant, ob eventuell jetzt die,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung nicht
Letztendlich in der Umsetzung das Ende des Versandes stiller SMS bedeutet, weil der ganze Kram ja ehm mehrere Wochen gespeichert werden soll. Also da weiß ich nicht genau wie die Strafverfolgungsbehörden da in Zukunft agieren werden.
Vermutlich werden sie aber weiterhin stille SMS brauchen.
Weil ja in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch nur gespeichert wird, wenn eine Transaktion anfällt.
Ja nur noch um.
So.
Also die, die Personen, es gibt auch noch, also wie gesagt, das Feld des Location-Tracking ist groß und wenn ich hier kurz ein bisschen Eigenwerbung machen darf unter äh GSM Map Punkt ORG,
kann man sich für für alle Länder auch noch so Berichte anschauen, also brauchst du auch echt jetzt nicht unbedingt,
stille SMS, um herauszufinden, wo sich jemand aufhält. Ja, das geht eleganter.
Ähm kann ich gleich hier auch mal kurz zeigen, wenn wir nicht mehr podcasten. Aber ähm,
Genau, da haben wir, haben wir auf jeden Fall so ein bisschen so Angriffe erklärt. So, die andere Sache ist, Insi-Catcher und der Insi-Catcher ist quasi etwas ein Gerät, das sagt, ich bin.
Ein ich bin dein Mobilfunknetz. Ja und das Telefon authentifiziert sich dann bei diesem,
Weil das Signal stark ist, ja? Also das das Telefon fährt,
die Lande und während es so und kriegt halt die ganze Zeit
Signale von den unterschiedlichen Zellen des Mobilfunknetzes,
einer Zelle nach der anderen an. Und zwar immer bei der, die das äh stärkste Signal hat. Und,
geht im Prinzip hin und sagt, hallo, ich bin eine Zelle von deinem Mobilfunknetz, ich sende dir, wie du merkst, ein sehr starkes Signal und das Telefon sagt, ah super, dann gehe ich doch jetzt mal in diese Zelle.
Jetzt unterscheidet sich das auch wieder nach zwei G, drei G und vier G, ich will da aber nicht zu sehr ins Detail gehen. Ähm letztendlich sagt das Telefon hallo, hier bin ich,
Ich darf das, hier ist meine Sim und so weiter, hier sind, hier ist meine lass uns mal hier 'ne Dingensauthentifizierung, das Mobilfunknetz sagt dann, das gefälschte Mobilfunknetz,
kann dann auf unterschiedlichen Wegen reagieren, zum Beispiel kann es sagen, ah wunderbar, alles klar, dann bleib mal hier.
Ähm oder es sagt halt, ja, alles klar, wunderbar, du bist das, äh aber ich nehme dich nicht an, ja?
Kann man auf verschiedene Wegen machen, da hab ich zusammen mit Luka und Deckstar beim Camp,
ein äh einen kleinen Workshop artigen Vortrag zu gehalten im BER Village, äh wo ich nochmal die verschiedenen Typen von ihm sehe. Ähm,
erklärt habe. Aber ein sagt quasi am Ende, der liefert am Ende die Daten folgende ähm im süß,
haben sich bei mir angemeldet. Ähm das heißt, da hast du quasi zu einer Location.
Die Opfer, ja, wird äh gerne mal eingesetzt bei äh.
Bei Demos wird aber zum Beispiel auch, dass es immer die Legende, mit der der Einsatz von von oder die Anschaffung von INCE catchern äh gerechtfertigt wird,
Ja, wir haben ja andauernd äh Selbstmorde, äh die sich irgendwie, die am Telefon sagen, sie bringen sich jetzt um
und dann müssen wir mit dem die orten, weil die sind dann im Wald, im dunklen Wald und dann haben wir quasi so einen Imseketcher mit einer Richtantenne und dann dann catchen wir die und dann mit der Richtantenne gehen wir dann dahin, dass das Signal stärker wird und dann retten wir deren Leben. Das ist so
ernsthaft die die Legende, die du immer wieder hörst, wo die die Polizei dir erzählt, warum sie diese brauchen.
Auf diese Methode schon aus dem Wald gezogen.
Weiß ich nicht, wahrscheinlich haben die Selbstmorder äh Ketchup, Ketchup oder Snoops und sehen dann, dass dann ist und schalten ihr Telefon aus. Also ich habe keine Ahnung. Das ist doch, ich meine, auf so einen Quatsch braucht man sich da gar nicht einzulassen.
Na ja, vor allem stehen die nicht häufiger auf der Autobahnbrücke, als im Wald.
Die Bundespolizei dreißig Mal.
Das sind ungefähr die Zahlen aus dem äh vorherigen Halbjahr. Und.
Dann ist ja aber im Prinzip der INSE-Katcher.
Komplett uninteressant.
Wenn du dir nämlich über die Funkzellenabfrage Gedanken machst. Das Einzige, was der IMSE-Catcher noch hat, ist, du könntest den jetzt halt so konfigurieren, dass er halt,
sehr viel genauere Auflösung hat
Örtlich, ne? Du weißt einfach, wo der steht, wie stark der sendet
und wer da äh wer da gecatcht wird, da kannst du halt dann nochmal, sage ich mal, genauer sein als jetzt zum Beispiel mit einer Funkzelle, die irgendwo aufm Land steht.
Im Prinzip vor ein paar Jahren so.
Recherchiert und der Öffentlichkeit zugetragen hat, nämlich dass sie.
Verstrafverfolgungsbehörden zum Provider gehen und sagen, ey, Kollege, wir wollen gerne wissen, alle, die sich zu diesem, in diesem Zeitraum in dieser definierten Zelle eingebucht haben.
Und ähm da hat man natürlich so ein ähm.
Mitunter halt viele hundert oder viele tausend Leute, ne? Wir hatten das ähm die zwei großen, interessanten Fälle waren einmal, dass die äh dass das in Dresden bei den Demonstrationen zum.
Spinner da aufmarschieren. Nee, das ist ja das sind ja auch die besorgten Bürger, aber die
Nazis, wo man auch weiß, wo die auch Nazis heißen, glaube ich,
Nee, was sind das immer in Dresden? Das sind dann.
Die gedenken dem Bombenterror oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Die besorgten Bomben
Terroristen oder sowas ist das, wo die dann der Bombardierung Dresdens gedenken, ne, und den Heldentod, den da alle geschoren sind und so. Das ist doch bei im Rahmen dieser Aktion sind ja dann immer große äh,
große Proteste und da hat haben dann die Strafverfolgungsbehörden auch äh Funkzellenabfragen gemacht,
in der kompletten Dresdner Innenstadt und hatten damit einfach mal alle, die bei dieser Demonstration waren. Ja, oder bei beiden, ja,
also konnten einfach mal, haben die haben einfach eine Liste aller Personen, die zu dem Zeitpunkt in Dresden waren,
auch eine sehr, sehr grundrechtschonende Maß.
Aller, aller Personen, die ein Mobiltelefon dabei hatten und äh plus alle Leute, die da zwar waren, aber damit nichts zu tun hatten und oben stehen.
Ja, sie haben einfach eine Liste aller Mobiltelefone aller Mobiltelefon, Identitäten, also es ist ja nicht das Mobiltelefon, sondern eher also es geht ja eher um die Sim, weil die Sim ja gebunden ist an die Telefonnummer und die Telefonnummer wiederum an die Person.
Massenüberwachung. Ähm,
einundvierzig Mal zum Einsatz gekommen,
Von der Bundespolizei und vom Zoll neununddreißig Mal zum Einsatz gekommen im zweiten Halbjahr zweitausendfünfzehn. Das heißt insgesamt also,
BKA zwanzig Mal, das heißt ähm hundert Einsätze in.
Hundert Funkzellen abfragen in einem halben Jahr. Ne, dreihundertfünfundsechzig Tage.
Durch zwei gleich hundertzweiundachtzig einhalb in hundertachtzig Tagen,
einhundert Funzellen abfragen. Das heißt schon so ungefähr jeden zweiten Tag.
Ist ja auch eine Menge los, also die da immer wieder Leute auf die Straße.
Na und bei jeder Funktion Abfrage, wie gesagt, da hast du halt, wenn du sowas jetzt hier in Berlin machst, wie sie's damals gemacht haben, als hier dieser äh dieser Frust hier rumgerannt ist und Autos angezündet hat, haben sie auch Funkzellenabfragen gemacht. Wenn das in inner Stadt wie Berlin Master,
Gleichzeitig ähm Hass,
hast du da natürlich auch eine relativ effektive.
Ähm Methode, um eine Person zu ermitteln, ne, also die haben halt im Prinzip einfach,
wenn er so ein Auto gebrannt hat, haben sich kurz die Funkzellendaten geholt, das machst du dreimal, dann bleibt einfach nur eine
eine Identität über die an allen drei Orten waren, ne? Das ist einfach über zufällig nicht mehr zu erklären,
Jeweils nachts eine Person sich in der Stadt aufhält, vor allem wenn du das dann an unterschiedlichen, in unterschiedlichen Stadtteilen machst und so, ne? Das ist halt relativ.
Relativ zügig.
Aber so so richtig aufgeklärt wurde, doch darüber.
Äh ich glaube, sie waren dann irgendwie nicht klug genug, das richtig auszuwerten. Am Ende haben sie den irgendwie, glaube ich, über eine Überwachungskamera oder sowas gefunden, aber der die Funkzellenabfrage hatte auch eine Rolle gespielt. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist so dieses.
Mobilfunk, so große Sache, ne? Also Mobil äh Funkellenabfrage jeden zweiten Tag.
Im Sequetcher stehen überall äh rum, weil wie gesagt, die eigentlich relativ selten zur Anwendung kommen und ich auch,
Im Sequetcher zum Einsatz zu bringen. Der ist der Einsatz eines ist einfach,
zu aufwendig im Vergleich zu den anderen Methoden, die die dir zur Verfügung stehen.
So viel zur Mobilfunküber zu dem neuesten Kennzahlen der äh Mobilfunk Überwachung. Dann haben wir ein ganz interessantes äh Urteil des in,
Im Vereinigten Königreich. Wir erinnern uns, dass äh David Miranda.
Der, ich glaube, inzwischen ehe man von ähm.
Heftig gerne auf die Sprünge.
Vielen Dank von Glen Green World. Ja, äh in an einem Flughafen lange Zeit festgehalten wurde, nämlich äh neun Stunden,
Das auf Basis eines Terrorgesetzes aus dem Jahr zweitausend, das es den Sicherheitsbehörden erlaubt, Reisende zu befragen, um herauszufinden, ob sie Terroristen sind.
Fragst du einfach. Ne.
Dabei haben die Personen weder das Recht, zu schweigen.
Noch das Recht auf juristische Beratung. Das sind also das,
Das Recht zu schweigen und das Recht auf juristische Beratung sind ähm fundamentale Errungenschaften des Rechtsstaates, ja? Ähm.
Die hast du dann eben nicht. Und du kannst bis zu neun Stunden festgehalten werden.
Ähm und.
Dagegen hatte eben der David Miranda geklagt, weil er ja als äh Journalist und so da festgehalten wurde.
Und ähm.
Hatte sich eben dagegen gewehrt und dann hatte stand das vor dem, hat der äh der Hykord hat,
Festnahme für Gesetzmäßig erklärt, weil es ja eben eine Gesetzmäßige Grundlage gibt,
Nämlich dieses Terrorgesetz aus zweitausend,
und da dagegen ist er eben in Berufung gegangen und hat jetzt hat dieser Court of Peel gesagt, ja,
was da geschehen ist, war in Ordnung. Es gibt eine rechtliche Grundlage dafür.
Aber diese rechtliche Grundlage ist nicht rechtmäßig, denn wenn diese Bestimmung.
In Verbindung mit journalistischen Material genutzt werden,
es ging denn ja darum, wo sind die Snowden-Dokumente? Äh,
dann ist das nicht mit Artikel zehn der europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention vereinbar. Ähm und deswegen sei diese gesetzliche Grundlage, die den.
Nicht beschuldigten eine einen Anwalt unters Recht zu schweigen entzieht,
Setz dich nicht aus gegen gegen willkürliche nicht ausreichend gegen äh Willkür äh abgesichert. Was äh total skurril ist,
aber wie gesagt, das Recht zu schweigen und das Recht auf juristische Beratung,
sind sehr fundamentale Errungenschaften des Rechtsstaat
und das finde ich, das war mir schon immer irgendwie äh aufgefallen, deswegen wollte ich diesen Spaßfakt jetzt mal kurz,
äh hier nochmal anmerken,
Es gibt nämlich das sogenannte und das ist das, was äh US-Polizisten, die ihren Gefangenen
sagen müssen, wenn sie sie verhaften. Nämlich so, sie haben das Recht zu schweigen, sie haben das Recht zu einem Anwalt, wenn sie sich keinen Anwalt leisten können, wird ihnen äh von Gericht jemand gestellt und dann gibt's noch einige weitere,
Ja genau.
Ähm wenn es kein, wenn du keinen leisten kannst, geben wir dir den.
Ähm wenn du Fragen beantwortest,
dass ein Anwalt da ist, kannst du jederzeit trotzdem aufhören.
Und dann musst du sagen, sie äh hast du diese Rechte verstanden,
und,
Diese Warnung müssen Polizisten in den USA aussprechen.
Die heißen Miranda, weil es nämlich mal ein äh eine Person gab, die äh verhaftet wurde.
Ähm.
Und sich dieser Rechte nicht bewusst war. Und da gab's einen Supreme Quad Discision und deswegen gibt es halt,
Verpflichtung von Polizisten, dass sie das einer Person, eine Person darüber ähm belehren müssen,
und äh das finde ich halt ein ein Spaßeffekt,
müsst ihr auch noch machen. Das ist Miranda und Miranda, so.
Genau, das war mir ein Ernesto Miranda,
und das äh fand halt in den USA statt äh in Arizona und ja, ausgerechnet David Miranda werden dann sozusagen diese Miranda Rechte nicht zugestanden. Ist schon äh.
Kann man schon gar nicht mehr toppen irgendwie.
Ja, aber okay, da kann man also jetzt sehen, da wird also jetzt tatsächlich ein Gesetz, wo man sagt, du kannst neun Stunden ohne Anschuldigung festgehalten werden, hast nicht das Recht zu schweigen und nicht das Recht auf einen Anwalt. Da wird jetzt also vorsichtig angemerkt, dass das Gesetz nicht ausreichend dagegen abgesichert ist.
Willkürlich angewendet zu werden, also was willst du dazu noch sagen?
Genau, also dieser Code of the Peel ist in äh England im Übrigen, ähm,
ein Berufungsgericht äh auf höchster Ebene, also der hat sich da,
Heilkraut aufs äh sozusagen das oberste Zivilgericht, das hat sich ja äh anders also hat gesagt,
und dieses Berufungsgericht hat halt jetzt gesagt, na ja, äh.
Aber das Gesetz selber ist halt braun und muss äh geändert werden so.
Was ich auch interessant finde eigentlich oder so würde man, ich hätte erwartet, dass in also in Deutschland hätte ich erwartet, dass man sagt, na ja okay,
Das war auf Basis eines Gesetzes, das nicht gesetzmäßig ist, also war's auch grundsätzlich, Mist.
Ja, würde damit hinfällig werden. Ich weiß ja nicht,
jetzt schon äh das letzte Wort ist in dem ganzen Spiel. Auf jeden Fall sagt das ja im Prinzip, dass dieses Gesetz weg muss.
Ja
Oder es muss noch irgendeine Klausel rein, um um ein absolutes Willkürgesetz, wo man keine Begründung, keine Beschuldigung, kein gar nix haben muss, äh irgendwie gegen Willkür abzusichern. Viel Spaß dabei.
Ja dann.
Letzter Teil.
Neues, Nähe, Vorletzter Teil. Neues aus dem äh aus der Generalbundesanwaltschaft,
Ähm Hacking ist not anout in the Bundestag. Ist jetzt äh Peter Frank,
losgegangen und hat die Ermittlungen übernommen. Ähm.
Wer ist Peter Frank.
Peter Frank ist der Generalbundesanwalt.
Der Neue, der Nachfolger, der der Alte, der Alte ist ja weggebrochen.
Der eine war irgendwas mit Landesverrat.
War irgendwas, irgendein Abgrund in den er hineingestürzt ist. Tja,
Da ist Herr Frank noch nicht ganz gelandet, äh deswegen entscheidet er sich jetzt halt auch mal irgendwann mal Ermittlungen auch aufzunehmen. Äh wir erinnern uns, der alte Bundesanwalt hatte ja
Probleme, zum Beispiel mal Ermittlungen aufzunehmen wegen dieses Spionageskandals in Deutschland, von dem man immer wieder mal hört,
weil da gab's ja irgendwie nicht so viele Anzeichen. Also da wird nur seit Jahren drüber berichtet, aber das äh heißt ja noch,
nichts. Aber hier wurde zumindest einmal bemerkt, dass doch tatsächlich so eine Hackattacke gab und jetzt äh
Ja, jetzt können äh die Bösewichter halt einpacken, weil der Generalbundesanwalt hat angekündigt, sich drum zu kümmern.
Er
Bereits also die zuständige,
Fachabteilung zu Bekämpfung von Spionagedelikten,
Also die Fachabteilung der Bund-Generalbundesanwalt,
führt bereits seit Mitte Januar. Wir haben gerade Mitte Januar,
ein Strafverfahren gegen unbekannt. Es geht um den Verdacht der geheimdienstlichen Agententätigkeit und,
Man hat natürlich immer noch keine Angabe über konkrete Spuren, aber der Finger zeigt nach Russland.
Das klingt alles wie so ein bisschen Neuigkeiten aus dem letzten Jahr, sind's auch. Wir hatten das damals auch äh ausführlich behandelt. Jetzt äh ist es auch bis zum Generalbundesanwalt durchgedrungen.
Muss aber auch dazu sagen, es gab quasi vorher eine ein,
LKA, wenn ich das jetzt richtig stehe, was sich damit schon auseinandergesetzt hat,
hatte jetzt übernommen, ja? Ähm.
Wenn ich das äh richtig verstehe. Aber okay, also der kann jetzt, es kann sich nur noch um Jahre handeln.
Und dann haben wir noch eine letzte Kurzmeldung aus der aus der Bundeswehr.
Wir hatten ja beim äh Camp eine eine Sendung mit den Gästen Julia Reeder und Andre Meister und Andre hat sich ja dann damals äh,
mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt, dass die Bundeswehr jetzt in den Cyber will und dass die Bundeswehr sagt, okay, es gibt äh Land, Luft und See.
Das sind unsere traditionellen Einsatzgebiete und jetzt,
ein viertes dazu und das heißt Cyber. Und äh.
Die Bundeswehr hat ja, wer im Namen und will sich verteidigen und hat irgendwie die ganze Zeit von ähm.
Von defensiven äh kleidet sich mit defensivem Gedanken gut
Wir erinnern uns an die Debatten der, die so in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren die Bundesrepublik beschäftigt haben
wo die wo die Bundeswehr überall,
unsere Freiheit verteidigt und so, mit welche Länder sie dafür reist. Ähm.
Also zum Beispiel am Hindukusch.
Kuschelt unsere Freiheit verteidigt und.
Demnächst halt auch an der Firewall.
Unsere Freiheit wird auch an der Feierruhr verteidigt.
Firewall verteidigt.
Ähm.
Ja und da war aber immer noch so von passivem, von passiver Abwehr die Rede,
jetzt stellt sich raus, man will natürlich auch äh sich auf Cyber-Attacken vorbereiten.
Ähm.
Nicht die nicht die Abwehr, sondern die Durchführung von.
Genau, die also laut in einem Sachbestandsbericht informierte das Verteidigungsministerium,
den Bundestag darüber, dass Abwehrkonzepte, die über den Rhein,
passiven Schutz zur Minimierung der Auswirkungen eines Cyber-Angriffes hinausgehen. Und diese würden bereits von der NATO unter
sucht. Und sobald die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen für solche
Cyber Defense Operation gegeben sein, würden die Möglichkeiten zur Unterbindung und Beendigung eines Angriffs bei der Bundeswehr geplant und ungesetzt.
Also ja, das ist wieder natürlich sehr schön in sehr schönen,
sehr schöne Wort, Worte, die da sind, also man man bleibt natürlich dabei, wir werden,
im Angriffsfall uns verteidigen mit,
Angriffen, denn Angriffe sind ja die beste Verteidigung. Das scheint das irgendwie zu heißen. Es ist auch ganz interessant, dass sie sagen, sobald die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen geschaffen sind,
glaube doch eigentlich, dass der Bundestag die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen setzt für die Bundeswehreinsätze oder nicht?
Na also äh wenn wenn der Einsatz ähm also wenn ein Einsatz.
Vorgenommen werden soll, muss der Erhalt äh in der Regel von Bundestag abgesegnet werden. Weiß nicht, ob die da jetzt über einzelne IP äh.
Fünf Jahre sein.
Aber nur in einem bestimmten IP-Adressraum.
Ja, wir teilen euch jetzt hier mal ein Subnetz zu. Da könnt ihr dann äh ja, schwierig.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist ja irgendwie auch ähm.
Nachvollziehbar, dass hier Besorgnis herrscht, ne? Aber äh Angriff als Verteidigung, da gehe ich nicht mit.
Na, sie werden das halt ach, ich weiß es auch nicht.
Also sie stehen auf jeden Fall irgendwie ähm.
Gewehr bei Fuß.
Sagt man? Das ist digital.
Tastatur im Anschlag.
Die Tastatur im Anschlag. Haben wir's?
Ja ich ich bin mit meinem Latein am Ende.
Bist mit deinem Datei am Ende.
Am Ende auch nicht.
Am Anfang. Ja, also was soll auch nur so Astrid Latein so.
Ja
äh weiß nicht, haben wir noch irgendwelche Termine anzukündigen, liegt irgendwas an? Von Abend, der ist dann äh bei.
In zwei Wochen der.
Der Dienstag im Monat, genau, ich dachte, wir machen's jetzt einfach mal konkret,
also in Berlin ist und äh sich da beteiligen will, dass der zweite. Zweite Februar,
Ja, vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier,
PN und ähm haben wir sonst noch was anzukündigen Linus?
Mir fällt gerade nix ein. Bestimmt, aber ich hab's nicht. Hast du was?
Ich könnte nochmal in eigener Sache darauf hinweisen, wenn ihr auf äh
Ebene ME geht. Ich äh habe jetzt vor ein Meter Podcast, den ich schon vor einiger Zeit mal so angefangen habe, häufiger zu pflegen und da auch mal immer äh in regelmäßigen Abständen darüber zu berichten, was so in den anderen Podcasts, die ich äh mache und begleite
wo ich vielleicht auch mal zu Gast war, äh passiert ist und warum
hier vielleicht mal weniger passiert und da äh mehr passiert oder auch,
Sendung ich persönlich für besonders gelungen und empfehlenswert erhalte.
Netzbild.
Wie zum Beispiel auch Netzpolitik, genau, das halte ich für besonders empfehlenswert, das solltet ihr euch unbedingt mal anhören.
Aber äh da würde ich mich äh freuen, dass dann auch äh nicht so epische Längen, wie wir sie heute zum Beispiel wieder
haben, sondern dass da mal so zehn, fünfzehn Minuten und das war's dann.
Wir brauchen irgendwann mal Logbuch light.
Meinst du jetzt mehr so von der Länge oder mehr von von Inhalten.
Von der Länge, wir könnten auch, was wir auch machen könnten, was ich aber.
Promi-Lockbuch könnten wir machen. Logbuch, Panorama oder so.
Oder so.
Nee, wo wir einfach mal nicht immer diese ganzen schweren, tiefen Themen mit Zukunft und Welt und Drama und Krisen und, und, und, und, und, und Krieg und so, einfach mal auch was fürs Herz, ja?
Gossip, ja, neues äh,
oder wer mag wählen nicht mehr.
Die Bunte.
Ja, genau, die Bunte, die Bunte, bunte Tüte für.
Ja, vielleicht fällt es dir was ein. Hm?
Scheiß auch nicht so ganz überzeugt.
Was ich überlege ist, ob wir nicht so dieses dieses Deutschlandfunkkonzept, ich finde das ja immer so geil, wenn du Nachrichten auf den Deutschlandfunk hörst, die Nachrichten im Überblick,
dann lesen sie erstmal so grob die Nachricht vor, da lesen sie die Nachrichten vor,
dann kommt nochmal der Zusammenfassung, ne, dann lesen wir nochmal die Nachricht.
Ach so, am Schluss.
Ja, damit ihr auch wirklich verstanden hast, das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ach so. Ach so, ne, das können wir doch hier auch einführen. Also Sie hörten heute.
Heute bei sie hörten gerade.
Genau, Alexander, das haben wir noch nicht gefragt. Who the fuck are you.
Ach ja stimmt, genau, das wollte ich auch noch fragen, genau.
Wer bist du und wer bezahlt dich? Ja. Was sind deine Interessen.
Deine Treppe. Das hat man ja eigentlich schon, ne?
Aber wer euch bezahlt hat oder nicht gesagt.
Ist, ob ein.
Wieso das denn?
Okay. Auch nicht schlecht. Was ist denn da?
Mit Facebook Geld verdi.
So, ich merke schon hier mit der Themenzusammenfassung, das wird nichts. Da müssen wir nochmal dran äh üben. Von daher äh verbleiben wir einfach so wie immer und sagen äh tschüss, bis bald. Danke Alexander, danke fürs Zuhören. Äh wir machen jetzt hier Schluss.
Ciao ciao.
Tschüss.